Hey, so right off the bat, I'm not sure if you guys are aware of this listener, you too. This is the start of our fourth year. We have completed three years as of yesterday. Right. Today is the first episode of our fourth year. So it's our birthday, third year birthday. Sorry.
I mean, we look just pretty humble. We look terrible for three years old, but we feel good. We feel young. And listen, I'm reading in the four. And we wouldn't be in our fourth year. If it wasn't for you guys, thank you very much for listening and caring and giving a poop about anything we have to say for God.
Thanks for not getting sick of Will and Sean yet. I mean, it's just, it's surprising. It's surprising. You're still here. Yeah. Maybe a little thanks to our team. Oh, yeah. Oh, shit.
And then thanks to our, and Bennett wanted me to mention thanks to the team, you know, who does it? Bennett and Rob and Michael, Bennett Barbarco and Robert Arnett. Arnett. Arnett. Arnett. And Michael Terry, who without them, well, we'd still make it happen to me.
We would just be bad. Our wings would not flap as fast. We would not fly as high. We just want to be good. We do it, but it would just, it would suck. That's certainly true. They make our lives better. And I also want to say shout out to the woman out there who comments on one of our posts
and said, uh, our net will just shut up. And, uh, and just say, you're heard. Anyway, happy birthday. Happy birthday. Happy birthday to us and to you guys and all of the smarties out there. Guys, yeah, here we are yep and it's a it's a podcast yeah let's get podcasting but wait and so yeah exactly so how do we get the podcasting to do it do it stretching or anything a vocal exercises yeah I'll do like. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it.
I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it.
I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Here comes Jay. Here comes Jason. Uh oh, everybody be nervous. What do you be nervous? What are you wearing? I'm wearing, it looks like a 12-year-old shirt with a... What's happening? Listen, he's playing golf today.
And with a long sleeve on? Well, that's... And it's gonna be warm out, dude. UV protection. Okay, I'm trying to be smart with the sun. And I'm also trying to be stylish at the same time. I've got on G4 here. You can't go wrong with that.
I give you a little fashion forward, you know. It's just forward towards. Careful. I know. I know. Okay. And the hair. And the hair is you can't pull it off.
I wear foot joy, which is what I'm telling you. And I'm tidalist. I wear the heritage brands. Uh-huh. And you can't pull that off. You can't pull off a heritage brand. Oh. It's not in your DNA.
Hey, you know, speaking of DNA, you know what today is, Jay, you know I talked about with you last night, but Sean, you're going to be excited. I've had to have coffee with no cream this morning. And, oh. Wait, now, did you start? What do you mean? Well, I started in a couple hours. Today, I got my first ever colonoscopy tomorrow.
Oh, so you can't do, I say. I can't eat anything. Wait, that's tomorrow. So you're doing a cleanse today. Yeah. Are you can't do, I say, can't eat anything. Wait, that's tomorrow. So you're doing a cleanse today. Yeah. Are you starving? Yeah, I'm starving in a chicken broth. I really, I've done this,
I've done this like three, four times. Why they're making you do it in the middle of the day. Three four times? Yeah, well, I had a situation back in that, when I was 30. Yeah, no, I was with you. I was with you. I was with you. You were 34.
I think you triggered it. But Jason and I were doing a scene from rest of them. We were in a fight scene. And all of a sudden he got, he went like white as a sheet. Like he was just exhausted. I just couldn't go any fight. I mean, you know, wheels of, you know, he's like wrestling, like wrestling a boa, you know,
that it's going to take some energy out of you. And Sean, he tried to wrestle me on the lake. The frozen lake and was going to die. Oh yeah. Well, and the funny of this fight was supposedly that it just went on and on and on and on. That was the joke. And we did have to do it for a long time.
Yeah. And I was like, I shouldn't be this tired. I'm not this out of shape. And so I went and saw a doctor and I'm like, I shouldn't be this tired. I'm not this out of shape. And so I went and saw a doctor and I'm like, oh, you're battling something. Is it turned out to be something in my GI? So anyway, they should only have you do this, like starting at like 6 p.m.
So you're on the throne for a few hours, you go to bed, you wake up, and you do your procedure. But they have two options, right? You could go five in the morning or like it. I'm going five in the morning. Yeah. Oh God, that in the morning. Yeah. Oh God. You should be able to eat all day, I think,
and then clean out at night. They claim no. They gave me explicit instructions. Starting this morning, do not eat anything. Only have bone broth. I should call Gwyneth. It was to her bone broth, actually. Could you start eliminating it? I have not. No, brother actually. Did you start eliminating it?
I have not. No, thank you. They also said that they now do the procedure in a big shower. They have an operating room that's also double as a shower. Is it the Bateman? Is it the Bateman? It's the new Bateman wing at Cedars. Cedars can clean as you go. Maybe you call it. Ask a bee's in the shower right now. Everybody's in a bathing suit. It's kind of hot. Sean, if you, oh yeah, no, you are, yes, you get the famous story about, you told them to leave your, your, your, your rear door alone. You said don't put my ass all right before you went in.
But wait a minute. I talked to a guy yesterday who had 35. Wow. He's that. He's a little bit of a fetish. yesterday who had 35. Wow. He's that. He's like a little bit of a fat. What do you mean, 35? He said 35, Colin Oscarbees.
That sounds like a, he had a kitchen, little shop of horrors. Right. When the boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom Remember that there was an episode of Arrest the development too. I know everybody's like, stop mentioning Arrest the development, but where the process character became addicted to the side effects of a drug, wasn't that? Well, I know you got a hair transplant and the hair transplant rejected the body instead of the body rejecting the hair transplant.
So his hair just kept growing more and more and more luxurious and his body was just atrophying. But he didn't want to reverse it because the hair was so beautiful. So he was willing to die. I remember him saying something about he used the word shunt at some point. Anyway, so, but tomorrow I'm expecting to be like a little thin 20 pound. Yeah, yeah, I can't do a lot of selfies tomorrow. When that when that bite comes out of your colon, that'll eliminate about nine pounds. You're going to be like a great white shark. They're going to cut you open. There's going to be stuff in there, Willie. Do you know how much ice cream they're going to find in there?
I know me too, my God. Is that your, is that your, well, who are you talking to the other night? It's a pine of ice cream every night. Other than John. Oh, no, Will's Jimmy. Does he a pint of ice cream every night? A pint of ice cream every night. He's a lean man. He's a thin man. Well, Sean, you're pretty lean and you you eat like you're going to the chair. Yeah, I do. I do have ice cream almost every night, almost every night. I do, I do, I go through phases where I'll have, but I lose it the next day. Yeah.
Well, we found it. You see what you found it again. Well, my cookie-paste. If you're looking for it, it's on your face. Okay, let's get into our guest. Wow. Guys, I've really upped my game today in the Cure Guest. This is my guest.
I don't know, I'm not even cool enough game today in the Cure Department. This is my guest. I don't know. I'm not even cool enough to ask him the dumb questions I have. You've upped your game to the Cure Department. Got it. Wait, this is something you need to ask the dumb questions. By the way, you can just go with the flow. No, I know, but I come prepared with some dumb questions. Did you write the central?
That's rare for you. This must be somebody you have respect for. I did write a little bit of it. Yes, you write yours. I do. Yeah, Willie just likes to kind of minor freestyle. Mine fun. Today, guys, we know him as a superhero and Hollywood heartthrob.
His lip sync battle mashup of Gene Kelly and Rihanna is still one of the most talked about and watched celebrity lip syncs of all time. One of the paltryl famously doesn't remember being in a movie with him. And before he entered the Marvel universe, he was performing ballet every night in the West End. It's the infectious, lovable Tom Holland. Wow. And I go, I use my morning Tom. Tom, can I call you Tommy?
Of course you can. Tommy, you've been on my list for like two years, and I've been trying to get you to come on the show. This is so exciting for me. You almost said a year, and then you doubled it. Yeah, I was a year, and then I remembered. It's been like two years. Wait, now Tom, you're a golfer.
I'm mad at you. What do you think about this beautiful G4 shirt I've done in New York? It's pink, it's got something. Something G4. Well, that's a great company. I want to give this a little surprise. I'm not sure about the underlayer.
Yeah, but there's Son out here. I'm not sure about the underlayer. Yeah, but if you're son out here, let him talk. I tell you what, actually, Jason, my brother Harry, we were shooting a movie in Atlanta, I think probably at the same time. He was at the Bobby Jones driving range and saw you there. We were going to go play golf, I think. And he said to me, I said, did you say hello? And he said, no, he's nursing a pretty intense slice right now. I didn't feel like it was the right time to go.
I would have struck him with my butt with my club. Just ripping slices off the teeth. Tom, I heard that by the way, great to meet you, man. And I heard from a mutual friend that we have actually that you are a great golfer. And he claims that you're like a two. Can you confirm that? I'm not two. No, I'm a four. Oh, yeah. But I played this weekend. I just went up and stayed to play golf to get away from the city and enjoy some golf. I was one over the front nine with
like some serious golf being played and 13 over the back nine completely. Well, because you're working too much. You need to be a, be a less good actor and you won't get hired. You know what they say? They say if you're shooting over 80, you have no business playing golf, and if you shoot under 80, you have no business. So. Let me ask you something. I don't know anything you're talking about.
What would my number be? 100. Well, probably. Yeah, probably. I bet you, a guy who probably have never played before, you get a triple bogey on every hall, so that's three times 18 is, what, 56? 56 on top is, yeah, that's about 130.
And so, and you're a four. I'm a four, but I'm a loose four. You know, I couldn't consider myself to be a true four. I just had some lessons. I had lessons. I'm a loose one, 30. How did you get so good at golf? You're so young, doesn't it?
It takes a lifetime to become a four, doesn't it? I think I just played as a kid. My dad was really into it. It's the thing that I've always done with my dad that we bonded over, that I've always had a lot of fun. And then I gave up for a long time when I just thought it was boring as a kid. I just couldn't get into it.
And then I was on set of Spider-Man 2. And I was outside. I ended up speaking to one of the chippies on set who was building some sort of spaceship or something. And he ended up playing golf. We were shooting out of golf course. We all ended up going out playing golf. And we all became best going out playing golf and
we all became best friends. I have a collection of like 10 people. If I'm back in London, I play every single day. And they're all, I mean, they're like plus one plus two, like proper, proper golfers. Yeah. So I'm constantly chasing them. But I had some lessons the other day with this guy who's fantastic. And I know that what he's saying will ultimately make me a better player, but right now I'm fucked. Like literally I'm missing both ways, fan it, thin and it, missing parts, it's tough out there right now. Yeah, yeah.
I feel you after now. Well, you're hitting all the stuff I wanted to talk about. Well, your questions are gone. I guess not. Oh, I thought you were going to say something like, well, you're hitting it out of the park with your career, Mr. Holland. Let me I thought you're gonna say something like well, you're hitting it out of the park with your career, Mr. Holland. Let me talk to you about that. Well, that would have been better. By the way, happy belated birthday. Thank you. June 1st. June 1st. June 1st. Well, how old is that make you?
27, my 27. Good. Good for you. Yeah. Do you guys remember what were you doing at 27, Willie? Why wasn't crushing it. I tell you that much. Sean, I got Will and Grace at 27. Did you really? Yeah, no, you go. I loved Will and Grace. I was always watching that my mom and I when I was a kid. Fuck me. I was going to say it was. I thought you were too young to know what that was. No, absolutely not. I love that show. You were born in Kingston upon Tames, is that I, is that? Or Tames, yeah.
The River Tames, yeah. Which I'm an idiot. West London, right? Correct. And you still live there? I do, yes. And who's in your house? In my house is me, my two brothers,
two of my best friends live with me. What about you? I went to drama school with. We have the most timid version of my best friends lived with me. Wait a minute. I went to drama school with. We have the most timid version of what a frat house would be. We're all obsessed with golf. We get early nights and we're on the tee early in the morning. So... Can I move in?
I know this is our dream come true. I actually have spare space, please. I'm loving what somebody has a deep allergy to golf, and it's not great for my game. I'm just picturing Jason living with all of you 20 somethings and there's a 54 year old living with 27. You have a room. You have a really grumpy hungry 54 year old.
Oh, I know my salads won't get eaten in the fridge. That's true. Those foods will still be safe. So hang on, it's your two brothers and two friends that eaten in the fridge. That's true. Those things will still be safe. So hang on, it's your two brothers and two friends that are in the house with you. Yeah, so it's me, Sam, Harry, and then Harrison and Twain. And we're all in there together. It's a pretty harmonious experience.
Everyone kind of does their bit. We look after the house, someone cooks. My brother, Sam, actually, thankfully, is a professional chef, which is a touch, like you come home and he's practicing and doing what he does best and you get gourmet food every night. Does he cook?
Every night? Every night, yeah, it's glorious. So he's rent-free then, right? Oh, absolutely, absolutely. He rent-free. And how much you want to bet there's a big TV in the house? There's a glorious TV. I just actually put in a little drop-down screen
for movies and we play poker, put the golf on and sit down. It's a glorious TV. I just actually put in a little drop-down screen for movies and we play poker put the golf on and sit down It's it's a vibe. Well, that's what I was doing. I'm moving out of You're ever in London and you want to play some poker and watch the golf on a Sunday night This master's weekend past weekend one of the best weekends of my life. Yeah, Tom We keep it going be 27 when you 27. Just knock it out of the park. Good for you. So you're the oldest of four boys, Tom, right? Yes.
And your parents were both artists. Tell me about like growing up and like with your, with your mom. Like what did your mom and dad do? So my mom's a, she was a photographer. And sort of like a lifestyle photographer. Like she'd take families out to the park and take pictures of them and do that sort of stuff
My dad's a stand-up and he has been since he was What? That's the one. I think Does he still do it? Oh, yeah, yeah, he's still gigging all the time and really He's a pleasure like he's hilarious. I can't bring anyone over to my house without him absolutely just ripping them a new one. And, you know, I have to like prepare my friends just so you know my dad's a standout.
Especially when I was young, I didn't understand what it was. I was like, apparently he fucking goes out and tells jokes at night or something. I don't know what it is that he does. He's gonna take the piss. And you guys basically provide him material, right? So, does all the family stuff work into his sets? Yeah, there's a few things.
I've been to see him a, like, a hand for the times when he'll allow us to go and see him. And I don't know if he, like, plays up to it that we're in the audience or if he, you know, if that's what he's like all the time, but it's pretty ruthless. But that's my poor mom. My mom has got the thickest skin of anyone I've ever met
in my life because the shit that he comes out with, I mean, he did a charity gig for my school, one else. So all my mum's best friends are there, all my kids, all of my school friends are there, all the school teachers are there, and the shit that he was coming out about my mum. It's a terrible idea. But the thing is, she finds it hilarious.
She's sitting there laughing, she gets the last laugh, and she's an amazing lady. I'm so sorry. Jason does some sort of thing. He's got one joke. It's great. Well, which one? God, please.
Please don't. No, I want to do a pro-todd. God, it's the worst. I don't know how to tell it, but it's funny. Just trust me, Tom, all right? So, and all your brother, everybody's in the biz. Well, it's so awesome. I mean, except for the chef.
Except for the chef. He's a caterer, onset caterer. On set caterer, we could get him in there, trap him in the cage that they keep those working. But everybody works as actors, no? Paddy's an actor, the younger one's an actor, but he's too young to really say he's an actor. He's like still at school, still enjoying himself.
He is lucky enough to be working in the summer and enjoys it. I don't think it's what he feels 100% that he wants to do. But he loves it, and he's really good at it. He's super, super talented, and he's very natural. My younger brother, Harry, who's here with me in New York right now, he's a young aspiring filmmaker. He has his first short premiering tomorrow at Tribeca,
which is super exciting. Oh, that's great. Oh, that's great. That's great. Yeah, that's really cool. We'll be right back. Smartlet's get support from Helix. You know, I'm in New York doing a show, as you well know,
but when I get home, I'm going to have my Helix mattress and I can't wait. I sleep so great. I'm in New York doing a show, as you well know, but when I get home, I'm gonna have my Helix mattress and I can't wait. I sleep so great, I'm a Helix mattress. To remind you, I got the Helix Dusk Lux mattress, but hey, we're all different. There's plenty to choose from. The Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses, including the award-winning Lux Collection,
the newly released Helix Elite Collection, a mattress designed for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids. Let's talk about the new high-end Helix Elite collection. It includes six different mattress models, each tailored for specific sleep positions and firmness preferences. Nervous about buying a mattress online, don't be. The Helix Sleep Quiz takes into account your individual sleep preferences to match you and your partner with the perfect mattress for you.
And your personalized mattresses ship straight to your door free of charge plus Helix mattress is all come with a 10 or 15 year warranty depending on the model. Helix is offering 20% off all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners. Go to helixleap.com slash smartless. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. With helix, better sleep starts now. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Smartless is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know when I was a lot younger,
as most younger people feel, you're a little lost about like, how do you do this, where do you go, if I want this for a career, if I want that for a relationship, if I want this with my friend, or if I don't want, you know, whatever your relationships are to all of the things in your life, you can feel uncertain about it, right?
I think we've all kind of felt that. And sometimes in life we're faced with tough choices and the path forward isn't always clear. I'm on Broadway right now, and of course, you know, even though I'm exhausted and I'm working all the time I can always find a half hour or an hour to speak to somebody if things start feeling overwhelming right so whether you're dealing with decisions around career relationships or anything else therapy helps you stay connected to what you really want while you navigate life so you can move forward with confidence and excitement trusting yourself to make decisions that align with your
values is like anything. The more you practice it, the easier it gets. It's actually exactly what my therapist says. I know every single time I talk to my therapist, I always, always feel better afterwards. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give better help a try. It's entirely online,
designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with the licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. Let therapy be your map with better help. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month.
That's betterhelp.htlp.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from CarMax. Sometimes the idea of selling your car can seem like a mystery movie, right? But with CarMax instant online offers, it can feel more like a rom-com, stay with me people. Now picture this, a person meets a sports car and falls in love. Then that person meets a person and they fall in love and start a family. Uh-oh, now that sports car has falls in love. Then that person meets a person, and they fall in love and start a family. Uh-oh, now that sports car has got to go. But don't worry, CarMax saves the day
with an instant offer at CarMax.com. Ta-da! Now our happy couple has a real offer from CarMax and can start searching for the perfect family car for that baby, baby, and live happily ever after. That's Car Selling Reimagined at CarMax. All right, back to the show. Does your dad, like,
does he hang out with other comics where there are other comics around the house growing up? Did you spend time with, are those his mates? Well, remember, like, his kids, like, going to barbecues and stuff and being aware of the comic scene and like knowing them as dad's work friends and just thinking like, wow, dad has like the strangest group of friends.
Like they are really sad people, man. Like I thought he was supposed to fucking make people laugh. And my dad is like, my dad is a very happy, go lucky, you know, positive guy. I feel like my dad's a giver. He comes into a room and he gives a great energy and fuck, some of his friends come in and you're like, wow, what happened to that guy?
You know, and then you see him on TV and you're like, he's hilarious. I think he's fantastic. It's a tricky one. Is his brand of humor, my mother's British. And so I got kind of like a dry appreciation for dry humor. Is he dry like that? Or is your humor dry like that? He's British. And so I got kind of like a dry appreciation for dry humor. Is he dry like that?
Or is your humor dry like that? He's dry. I'd say I'm pretty dry too. He lets the material do the talking. Like he's not a performative comedian. Like he really trusts his material and he belies on the joke and he knows it's funny. So he doesn't add to it.
Everything is very kind of one note. But I like that sort of thing. It means the material has to be better. Are you drawn towards comedy stuff? Do you want to start banging out a bunch of comedies and do that kind of thing? I've always, always, always wanted to do a comedy. It wasn't too long ago I was doing, I was in Brazil and I did this show for, I think it was part of my two, it was part of my one. It was like 7,000 people in the audience.
And I was on stage for an hour with a compaer who was like asking me questions and stuff. And it was the greatest experience of my life because I felt like a rock star. Like everything I said, everyone was fucking laugh. So I called my dad and was like, dad, dad. I just did like an hour on stage and like I fucking ripped the shit out of it.
Like let's do this. Like help me write some comedy. And he just hung out. He was like, it has never happened in some time. Really? But yeah, now I'm not bold enough to step on stage and do what he does. But I'd love to do a comedy one day.
Who are some of the actors that make you laugh that are like, are you like a welfare fan like me and those folks or do you like comedy that comes a little bit more from actors that are doing a character as opposed to being being broad or I guess Will does. Will does really deep characters that are like he's a lot of will stuff. I love his his ability Will does really deep characters that are like he, those characters. I love Will's stuff. I love his, his ability to improv. The stuff that you do is my favorite without a shadow of a doubt. Well, but I'm not being funny, funny like our net or a feral or folks that really know how to get people. I'm the guy you turn to, to sort of like, the guy who's not laughing. Yeah, but that's funny though, I like that.
Is that dry humor? It's similar. They're right, right? Yeah, I love it too. I fucking love that line you do and you said, when you're driving in a Prius or something, is it in horrible bosses? Oh, all right, yeah.
He's like, you were tag racing in a Prius? I don't win a lot. I like that. That's what you're doing. That's what you're doing. Yeah, one of the things I think is super cool is that you're a straight guy who took ballet lessons. I think that's, you know, not that straight guys can or just gay guys do or whatever, but it's like, you know what I mean?
It's refreshing to see you tackle that. And was nine years old? Was that what it was? Yeah, I was I was I was training for this show on the West End at the time, called Billy Elliott. Yeah. And I went to like a very traditional rugby school. I was pretty good rugby player as a kid and then everyone just grew and I stayed the smallest kid even today. I couldn't compete in the under 12 league. I'd be too. So it's taken some injuries. And I just, I remember like getting bullied at school and trying to convince people like,
guys, there's me and 30 girls in tights on a daily basis and telling you like rugby is not where this is at. Like, you join me. But I could never convince anyone. But I loved ballet. For me as an actor, like, especially doing things like Spider-Man, that are so physical.
It comes in handy. It's been such a great resource to rely on. And that's that I've lost every ounce of flexibility. But you're obviously a big, and you mentioned that you played rugby a bit, and that you like sports, you like golf. I saw you waving the checkered flag in Monaco last week. Yes, that was crazy.
It's great going to those races, isn't it? Dude, like one of the best weekends I've ever had. I took all my brothers, I took some friends, and until you've been there and like seen it for real, you're hearing it. And hearing it? And you feel it, right, when they, I mean, it's insane. And it like, you can feel your ribcage.
Especially there too, all those engine it's insane. And it, like, you can feel your rib cage. Especially there, too. All those engine noises going through all those buildings, through those corridors. Right, it's just the actual... And also, like, at the end of the day, like, qualifies done, they open the track. You can walk from restaurant to restaurant, via the track, and, like, see the tire marks across the floor.
It's, it's, unlike, I love sport, I'm obsessed. It's, like, it's, you know, I'll watch anything that's on telly. Yeah, do you watch, are you watch, are you a big football fan? I'm like a soccer fan. Yeah. Yeah, I'm a Tottenham fan, regrettably. Are you? Yeah, it's tough, man.
Man, this is a tough spell you guys are going through. I mean, you've got that new manager, but still it's a tough time to be. We didn't care for Tottenham, Willie. You sure did, yeah. It's all about Garas Bale. Yeah, we played golf with Garas Bale. We played the Bunch. He's a good golfer, I had He sure did, yeah. Yeah. Yeah, we play golf with Garrett the bunch.
Yeah, he's a good golfer. I have really good. Yeah, he would love him. Yeah, he's got a really pretty swing, doesn't he? Yeah, yeah. Willie, you into your socket? You sported too? Yeah, yeah, I'm a Liverpool supporter.
We're a Liverpool supporter. Okay. Yeah, I'm a massive, massive supporter I watched. I was at World Cup. I mean, I'm a massive fan. Oh, wow. How did you come to Liverpool? My partner, my writing partner, not just to clarify. Yeah, I know you're straight.
It's take a minute. I don't know. I'm just, I would do ballet too, by the way. I have no problem. Come on, let's do it. I would, I would. Mark Chappell, the great chap, he whom these guys know is.
Once in a lifetime. He lives in London. He lives in London, but he's a big Liverpool sport and he got me in deliver pool. Okay. And I was saying the other day, like I wasn't really as aware of it. I mean, I love any sports. Jason's the same. I'll watch anything. So...
And then got into soccer, you know, football like 12 years ago. And once I got into it and got deeper into it, it just, yeah, I'm a massive hockey fan growing up in Canada. And then football has now surpassed hockey, I think. I just, I can't get enough of it, man. Do you guys know all the chance, you know, I think it's so cool that there's, I wish we had chance in baseball, you know.
Some of the chance, like, I remember going to see a basketball game in New York and people like, dude, you're not going to believe the atmosphere. Like, it's going to blow your socks off. And then you get there and it's like, let's get louder. And I'm not just trying to shut up. Like, let's come up with something better than this. Wait, Jay, they have that organ.
Da, da, da, da, da, da. Oh, I know. That's it. It's a one word chant. Yeah. The chant, the chant in football in Europe and in England, in the Premier League are not only they so good, some of them are so clever and hilarious.
And they just sound haunting as it goes through the quarrel. And you go to some of these places, you go to Versailles, you go to Marseilles, you go to Germany, Dortmund, and see these teams, like the way they rally together, and how song just like explodes out of people somehow in unison. I don't understand how it happened. That's a true home field advantage. The first, the first professional football match I went to is in Madrid for Atlético Madrid
at their old stadium. And I was not, and it was Sunday night game. I remember it like sort of eight o'clock. And I was not prepared for the chance and the feeling in the crowd. Nobody sat the entire match. Everybody was standing and it was electric. Just even if you were in a fan of the sport as a human being, it was an experience. Now, are you still watching rugby? I like rugby. I mean, I love rugby. I love the sport. I think it's amazing. I don't love rugby culture. Right. Oh, yeah.
Rugby culture is so much about like, how much can you drink? Let's all get as drunk as possible. And I don't drink. So I'm a little bit like out of that world. Right, right. Do you ever see Australian rules? Aussie rules is crazy. Yeah. It's sort of a hybrid of soccer. It's good. Have you ever been to one of those matches down there? It's amazing. I haven't known. It's someone like, have you ever seen Gaelic football?
Oh, yeah. Gaelic football is, I guess, like, the Irish equivalent to Aussie rules. Oh, yeah. But another sport you should check out, I think it's called herlling. Yeah, herlling. And they have, like, a hockey stick. But the end of the hockey stick is slightly wider. Right.
They have, I think, as a wooden ball. And they basically, like, flick it up. They have, I think it's a wooden ball. And they basically like flick it up. And they catch it on it and they, they have bloody, they're bruised. It sounds like you can get hurt. It's sort of like, it's polo without the horses. Right?
That's exactly what it is. Sounds like quidditch. Quidditch. Oh, she's so edgy. Hey guys, hey guys, what's up? Quick, quick, quick, quick shout out from the nerd department. Hey guys, that reminds me a lot of Quintet, Shay. And according to the rules, Hey, Tom, how did with all of this,
what was your first, how did you start? What was your first thing as an actor? Like, what your first thing where you're like, I got it, I want to be an actor, I want to do this. I want to be in a play. I want it like, what was your first thing as an actor? Like, your first thing where you're like, I got it, I want to be an actor, I want to do this, I want to be in a play, I want it, like, what was it? Apparently I used to love this one Janet Jackson song when I was a kid. Which one?
I live for her. Oh boy. I don't know what it is, but apparently my mom posted it for my birthday, a video of me as a kid dancing to it, and apparently Janet Jackson actually reposted it. Like, was it like rhythm nation or something like that? I don't know, I could find it. But anyway, my mom just...
I was one of her backup dancers. I was one of them. Yes, I was one of them. I was on a little grace and Sean and I had it. You were the picture of the hands, that wasn't you? No, Sean and I had a dance off on an episode of Will and Grace once. With Janet Jackson.
With Janet Jackson. Jason came to taping. Yeah, you got to Google that, Tom. It's life-changing. I'm going to look that up. Yeah, it's pretty good. But I'm... Okay, so wait, so you were in a Janet.
I would do these hip-hop glasses on a Saturday, and I got spotted by this headmaster of this school to audition for Billie Elyette. They started training me and doing ballet, and all that sort of stuff. I ended up auditioning for this show, because I thought it would be fun. I enjoyed the process of auditioning.
I got the gig. I got an agent through the gig. My parents were like, well, I mean, there's no harm in having an agent. They sent me one screen test, self-tape for a film. I did it, I was like 12, and I got the part, and it was this film called The Impossible
when you were in the box, because about the tsunami. It's another film called the impossible. Yeah, the impossible. Because about the tsunami. It's another one of your questions, Sean. I'm sure. It's definitely. And then I just... Good for you, Tom. You get the picture now.
You're getting it. Welcome to our life. And then I just never stopped doing it. I just kind of, I guess I reached that age where I was maybe 16, 17. I was like, I can either keep my head down and like stick with school and try and figure out what I would do if I'm going to get millions and crushing ass, right? It's a tough choice. Tom, it sounds like from a young age you had very naturally what Jason likes to call sexy and difference. We'll be right back after these things.
Um, because you guys don't care. I love that he's like, I just didn't care. And I just thought, yeah, I got this part. I know what I got this movie in and look what happens. Meanwhile, Sean is begging. He's that casting director. His doors are just flocks. Like begging.
I got a new headshot. I don't know if you've seen it. Make a cross. He did. He did. He did. He did. He did.
He did. He did. He did. He did. He did. He did. in a fucking Hawaiian punch commercial, you know, I mean, just, I'm pleased. My payment with free product. Tom, when did you start perfecting your American accent? Because it's just, it's, it's, it's, it's seamless. It's very, it's very, it's very, it's very, it's very, it's,
and is it hard, I've asked this before, is American accent hard to do? I think as a Brit, we're so, uh, like surrounded by American culture. We watch your shows, we watch your films, we listen to your music It's a big part of our lives by color. The way it's same. We watch, we're patch away with it. Right, but we don't understand all the class differences of the British accent. Right. I do. But yeah, I don't know. Somebody was on, I can't remember who we had on. They said one of the hardest words to say in the
with an American accent being a Brit is murderer. Murderer. Oh, that was good. Yeah, that's not easy. Murderer. Murderer. Oh, shit. Peter Parker.
I find L's difficult to say. Can you say Arnold Palmer? Arnold Palmer? See, that's hard. It's not really. It's good. Arnold Palmer. Yeah.
Now, do you get, do you get, it would be hard for me to do an accent as an actor because I would be thinking more about the pronunciation instead of the performance. Is that a hard thing for you to separate? I think for me, with accents, I like it because it's like an immediate, different side to yourself. I think the jobs where I've struggled the most is where I'm doing it in my own
accent. Oh really? It doesn't feel like enough of a departure from who I am. You have trouble leaving Tom. Yeah, and I don't know. My dad's, you know, he's a comic so he's always grown up doing accents is something he's really good at. We grew up with him doing it all, allways around the dinner table. So I love doing accents. Now it sounds like you have a theory. Have you done it? Have you tried a British accent? I mean, a bit here and there. Yeah, but I would know. I know it's going to be great. No, you know what? Right now. I mean, I would, I would do it. If I got cast in a part, I would definitely, I wouldn't, I wouldn't shy away from the part. But I do think there is, there is something to focus on. Will, you say you've got your hands around the class differences and all the different
English. I can, yeah, I understand. Yeah, I could hear Tom's accent, which is, and I figured you were sort of like Eastern Northeast London. Am I right about that? Southwest London, but really that's Southwest. I have a bit of a weird accent. I don't really sound like where I'm from.
I sound the people I'm surround myself with. Most of my mates are all facky, caught new blind. Yeah, that's why you have a little... Yeah, you have a little bit of that. Like, just get the job done, do the job. Yeah, right, I try. I've lost a sort of posh twang I grew up in. Yeah, my name is Ronda.
Telling me how I shouldn't speak, darling. My name's Ron, I'm a placer. He's Rody's a plumber. You know, we follow the spurs. That's not bad at all. And also because I'm spurs as well, you'd think I'm your flundering. So you say, well, the people you surround yourself with, it does sound like you keep a very normal circle around you, and that that's not a struggle for you. You seem like a very, very normal guy. Is it something that you battle with all of this fame, unfortunate and permissive people around you? Is it tough for you to keep your head on your shoulders or does it come easy?
I don't think so. I think my parents did a good job of keeping us in check, especially later on. I think I've seen lots of friends where you become successful and all of a sudden, like, your parents rely on you to, you know, bring in the bread or keep the family going and stuff like that. And I've been really lucky that my parents have never done that.
They've always been my parents. It's still, you know, I listen to my dad if he's got something he wants to say, he won't shy away from it. And then my friends, they're all golf lads, they're all my golf mates. All we do is play golf. There's no way I've gotten into trouble on the golf course.
I snap my seven eye on the other day, which is kind of the extent of my bad behavior in life. And I felt like breaking a club the other day and I was like, what's going on with me? It would feel so good. Yeah, it was great to have this right now. And the thing that was even worse is I peered it. I absolutely like, I played a little buttery cut,
like I really need this to land soft, and I hit the car path, and it just, tuh, and I just, over the back of my head, I was like, bow! Wait, wait, so Tom, when you were in the impossible, how old were you in that? I think I was just turning 14. Did you understand like the weight or the gravity of being in a big movie like that?
Or did you not even think about it? I actually think my youth was a real... It was great for me because I was so naive. I just looked at those experiences like a summer camp. It's only now that I'm a little bit older that I'm starting to really understand like the responsibility of being in a big film or a big show. I have my TV show come out. Right, right, right.
Yes, yes, yes, right. And so what's the show? Tell us about this show. The show is an anthology series called The Cratted Room. It's sort of my first kind of a Cuban Goldman, right? Oh yeah, Cuban Golds. It's a funny bars. What a great guy.
I love him so much. Yeah, we like Cuba. Honestly, like working with him was a dream come true. Like it was my first real time producing and he really took me under his wing and kind of explained to me the do's and the don'ts of how to do it properly. Yeah, he's just the sweetest, smartest,
most experienced guy. Yeah. Can't say enough of that. He's just the sweetest, smartest, most experienced guy. I can't say enough of that. He's so sweet. How old were you when you went from... When you got Captain America to the work? Because that was the first one, right? Were you played Spider-Man? Yeah, it was like 10 days after my 18th birthday. Wait, so that was before you did Spider-Man was... Yeah. Okay. Which was actually really great because it was somewhat like my audition for the general public. I got cast. There wasn't the greatest public feeling about me being cast. And then so before happened and for me it felt like my opportunity to like showcase what I could do in the character without having to take the weight of a standalone film. So I had a lot of experience in that movie.
Why do you say it wasn't recent? It's like the heavy duty fans were just... I don't know. I tried not to read into it that much. I guess I wasn't the top pick. I don't know how, but the list of the final six people got out. And I definitely was at the bottom of the list. So I think being cast was like a bit of a shock to the system. But then when Civil War came out and people were really happy with it and they really enjoyed my performance and thought it was really, you know, it was unique and different.
There was a big turnaround. So I was lucky to have Civil War. About the great Amy Pascal came in with her great taste and said, you know what, no, Tom is our guy. I love Amy Pascal. She's my mom away from home. What was your first experience, like meeting all the other Avenger to Actors? Were you starstruck? What was that like coming in first day at work?
I think it's that interesting thing where you just realize that everyone's actors wearing crazy costumes sitting on the same set chairs and the same Atlanta food, you know? Like, it was obviously really amazing and I was 18, a huge fan of those shows. So it was super exciting. I think Downey, yeah, you had to put up with Downey. He really does a good job of like setting the tone.
Oh, it does a good job. Of like how people should behave. He's on time. He professionally knows his lines. He knows everyone's name. He's respectful. I would you would you agree with me on this and the guys might too. Downey's the funniest motherfucker around. Yeah. Right. I mean, how fucking funny is downey? I love. He's the most frustrating scene partner out there. I can't help it. I'm not saying anyone like him. You sit down, you get sent the pages, I write stuff,
I try and come up with something funny, I'm trying to bring my flavor to, you know, sometimes he stale stuff. And you spit out your joke on set, you think that's going to land, that's so good, and he just uses your joke to set up his joke that's going to brush off the dome and you're like, that's so irritating. I love that. He is the best. Did he fly? Didn't he come in and like a helicopter or something or on the first?
Yeah, he did, yeah. We were, it was six of us, six kids that were auditioning. It's the weirdest kind of meeting I've ever had. Like, we're all sitting down, having lunch and like, eyeing each other up. And I'm like, I could probably take you lot physically. I don't know like how we could go in an acting thing. And then, and then, down he, yeah, he flew over us
in his helicopter, he landed on the, the helipad next door to the stage, he drove over. That's not helpful, you're already nervous. And then here comes your scene partner in a helicopter. I know. I'm such a hopeless optimist, though, like as soon as I saw the helicopter, I was like, I'm getting this part
and I'm flying away with him after the audition. I genuinely was like, this is that's how the day's gonna go. The audition went so well, I thought it was great, didn't hear anything for like seven weeks. What? At that point, you sort of go, you let it go, I didn't get it. Call me back for a second audition.
I did a screen test with Chris Evans, which was like a fight test. And, you know, I have a gymnastics background, so I was like, I'm fucking going above and beyond. I'm doing every flip, side flip, back flip, whatever I can do to get this part. I went home, heard nothing for like another four or five weeks, and then I was scrolling through Instagram, and Marvel had posted a picture of Spider-Man and said like, if you want to find out who the next Spider-Man is, go to our website. So I went to their website. And you're like, I want to know who the next one is. I was like, yeah, but the thing is, I was like, it's obviously not me because they'd have more
respect than just putting it online. They would call you. I went online, I read the headline, it said my name. Why? I remember like shutting my computer and being like, this can't be real. And this was also right around the time that Sony had been hacked. So I was like, there's something going on here. This is the right way. And then an hour later, I got a call from the studio. I got a call from Sony.
I got a call from my agents. Like, we don't know how this has been leaked, but we've cast you. Good luck. Like, we're really excited. But it was on the Marvel website? Yeah, so I think they just try to get ahead of the leak and make the announcement.
And then in every interview, basically said, that's how I found out, so that didn't work out for them. Uh-huh. But yeah, it was great. Now, what was your level of excitement must have been through the roof, obviously, but was your anticipation of what was to come accurate with what you now have lived?
Like, did you see exactly what was coming or has it been better or worse? It's been so much better. I couldn't, I could not have anticipated it being as fun as it was and how rewarding it's been. I think there's a stigma with those types of films. Yeah, but I've had a lot of that. You're a fault.
You probably have just really enjoyed it. You've been a great leader. You've had fun with it. And you've created a great environment for yourself and everybody else. That yields a lot of good stuff afterwards. Well, thank you. I appreciate that. Yeah, I think so. And I read, didn't I? Isn't it true that you've been a Spider-Man fans that yields a lot of good stuff afterwards, right? Well, thank you.
I appreciate that. Yeah, I think so. And I read, didn't I? Isn't it true that you've been a Spider-Man fans and you were a kid, right? On me. Like, my mom has got countless costumes that have never been washed
of when I was like a four-year-old kid for refusing to take it off. A really new bounce-in off of the bunk beds and stuff like that. I was obsessed. And there's actually an interview of me when I was maybe 15 on a red carpet. And someone said, like, if you could play any superhero, who would you play?
This is like seven years before it happened. Or maybe not as long as that. And I said, I'd love to play Spider-Man after Andrew Garfield. Like that would be my dream. And then fucking came true. That's crazy. Crazy is day of my life.
I couldn't believe it. And now you've gone on, you've done some really cool dramatic stuff in addition to that as well. That must be nice to kind of construct your year or a few years by, you know, sort of weaving in stuff that is very different from it and working with your folks to get all that stuff squared away. Is that your goal is to try to find a real balance with all that stuff? It's not necessarily something I particularly think about. I just... Yeah, man, not everybody's a psycho. Thinking about braiding everything in, you know what I mean?
I think the crowded room for me, like, yeah, it's a challenge and it's different. I think me and Kiva, you know, you know what he's like. He is an amazing guy. I think the show has an amazing message that's really important. And I just felt, I don't know, I felt compelled to kind of jump into it and accept the challenge and see how it goes. I love that.
And I don't know. I don't really know what I'm gonna do next. I have taken the year off. I haven't worked at all this year. I've just been at home, honestly, just playing golf every day. You deserve it. And now you have such a massive following, just huge.
I mean, it's, and do you feel, it sounds like a cheesy question, but I really mean it. Do you feel pressure or any kind of responsibility to be kind of like a role model, not that you asked for that? But it kind of just happened, or do you just go, that's not me, I didn't ask for it, and don't look at me as a role model, I'm just an actor, or do you embrace it?
I'd say something that really does stress me out, is that I am so severely dyslexic, that when I post on Instagram for something, I have to get like three people to proof, read, what I've written, it really, really stresses me out, because it goes out to a lot of people, and you don't look like an idiot, you know? Like my post. read what I've written. Oh wow. It really, really stresses me out because it goes out to a lot of people and you don't look like an idiot.
Right. Like my person. No, I guess I understand the responsibility. I'm lucky that I have someone like Zendair in my life. It's interesting being in a romantic relationship with someone that is in the same boat as you. Yeah. You can share your experiences and all that sort of stuff
and that's worth it's weight and gold. Yeah, for sure. I wonder because now you've done so many big movies in massive press junkets. And I remember speaking of, we started the interview saying, you're 27 years old, I was 27. And that's when I first was like, I have to do how many interviews and go where and what.
And it's like all of that press and the hours of the press junkets, which is an art in and of itself, by the way, but what about the first time you saw the amount of press required of you? Was that like, and do you like doing, because you're really good at it? Yeah, thanks. Yeah, I just always try and like,
smile and wave and never let them know how you really feel. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Like you're almost 60th in the interview of the day and someone comes in and they're like, what's out of the bed do you sleep on? And it's like, what the fuck off? Why do you wanna know that? Leave me alone.
Yeah, I mean, it's a bit of a minefield too, right? Because you do so much of it and I'll bet you probably wanna change your answer a little bit here and there just to keep yourself entertained. But then you might get into something that's a little bit spicier than you even mean to say and then now they've got a headline. And that's the thing they grab. And that's the thing that happened to me the other day. So I gave up drinking of January of last year. And by the way, congrats on your sobriety and
congrats on speaking so publicly about it and it helps lots and lots of people. So I could free up. That's a great, bud. Thank you. Yeah. So I gave up for a multitude of reasons, but really just because I wanted to take a break. Yeah. And in taking that break, it was the hardest thing I'd ever done. And was like, oh, maybe I should look at this a little bit more seriously. And elongate the break. Eventually I took it to my birthday, June 1st.
And by the time I done six months, I felt so amazing that I was like, I don't think I'll ever drink ever again. Wow. But I did an interview the other day for like an hour where I spoke about giving up drinking. And then about 45 minutes later, I told a joke about having a meltdown on set and wanting to cut my hair off. Because my hair was so crazy for this show. And the headline of the article was,
Tom Holland gave up drinking after having a meltdown on set. And it's like, that's not even... I know. It makes you just want to just stop. We're moving up, Trace. I know, it's all done. Yeah.
Well, it's really tough. It's not that spread. It's tricky. You got to pick and choose. Well, don't ever cut your hair. You got good hair. Yeah, it's really tough. That's right. It's tricky. You got it. You got it. You got to pick and choose. Well, don't ever cut your hair. You got good hair. Yeah, you do. Thank you. I like this bullshit. My dad the other day Jason was saying my dad said he said Jason Bateman. He's definitely got a syrupy knee and a syrupy in England means a wig. He's a syrupy and big wig. And I said,
no, I don't think so, dad. I think that's just his hair. My dad's obviously bitter because my dad bests of losing his hair. And he was like, that Jason Bateman, he's definitely wearing a syrup. I said, no, Dad, I'm genuinely thinking that just his hair. Yeah, no, plus Jason, never, there's this hair, which is astounding. He doesn't have a gray hair on him. Yeah, people think it's either it's plugs or it's color or both, and it's, it's just not. It's luck. It's just all you've got luck. It's going to be think it's either it's plugs or it's color or both and it's just not it's luck. It's just all you look It's gonna be it's gonna be thinned out Tom Holland, we've taken up way too much time. You're awesome. It's so nice to meet you I mean it's just and for so long and and and and it's like you emit exactly what you are exactly who I would hope
You'd be just like the coolest grounded nicest. It's exactly what we've heard. Keep it up, buddy. Yeah, man, I'm killing it. It's such a fun and a show. My brother and I were always listening to you guys. So it's an honor for me to be here. And we should play some golf and sure you should come.
Oh, come on, John. You know what, they'll count me in for the poker. I love poker. Okay, don't. If you're in London, we have a poker game, the first weekend of every month, if you fancy it, it's a lot of fun. I'm gonna hit you up, Tom, when I come to England
and we're gonna play. For 100%. And we'll go watch a football game. Yeah, fantastic. Wicked. Thank you, Tommy. I get to now call you. Absolutely.
Thank you, buddy. Have a great rest of the day. Thanks, pal. I appreciate it. Thank you guys. Bye, buddy. Oh, nice. Yeah. What a great guy. I said it. Thank you guys. Bye, buddy. Bye, bye. How nice. Yeah. What a great guy.
I said it at the end there. He's so wonderful. I didn't know that about his drinking. That's great. Good for him. Yeah, yeah. I wonder if that's tough with all the living and basically a frat house. I wonder if they're all not drinking too. That could be tough.
I'm always kind of astounded too when somebody like him who's so young and got such big, massive things happen for him in his career when he's so young. They always carry themselves so confidently and like, you know, not to repeat the Jason Bateman thing over and over again, but the sexy indifference like that. They always have this like swagger that's like, yeah, I'm good if we do it,
I'm good if we don't. Right. Like this like and and it's a confidence thing that I never had at that age. It's I don't know how and and so many people you have it you had it too Jay when you were younger too. They all have this like thing where I don't know how they how they learn that or where they get that from. Well mine mine was I bought mine and should have been renting it because it, it, it went away for me. And it was a, it was a, an uncomfortable correction when, you know, I had some, some quiet times. And it was like, oh, I don't feel so confident anymore. I'm no longer indifferent. I really want it back. And it hurt my ability to even get it back because now I'm walking into auditions desperate
and really wanting something. And you start squeezing the puppy and it starts to choke out. Yeah. I squeeze the puppy and sometimes it chokes out. Uh oh. Oh, okay. Tom Holland was so great, so great to have him on.
Love that Tom Holland. He's a, I don't mean this disrespectfully. He's a great kid. Great kid, you know. Well, because he looks, he wouldn't, I think he knows it. I used to be on my age. I'll tell you. It looks like, you know, it looks thin, you know, it might be, he maybe, he should have
a sandwich or maybe just order a nice big juicy rib. Bye. Bye. Happy birthday, Squirtle. Happy birthday, Squirtle. Happy birthday, Squirtle. Happy birthday, Squirtle. Happy birthday, Squirtle.
Happy birthday, Squirtle. Happy birthday. Happy birthday. Happy birthday, Squirtle. Happy birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Granterry. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondri app. I'm Leon Nefak, the host of Fiasco and the co-creator of Slow Burn. And I'm Jay Smooth, a hip-hop journalist and cultural commentator.
Michael Jackson was accused of child molestation for the first time in 1993. Our new podcast Think Twice, Michael Jackson, is the story of what came before and what came after. Throughout the podcast, we explore what makes Michael Jackson seemingly uncancelable. And we dig into the complicated feelings so many of us have when we hear Billie Jean at the grocery store. Through dozens of original interviews with people who watched the story unfold firsthand, think twice as an attempt to reconcile our conflicted emotions about Michael Jackson, the man with our deep-seated love of his art.
Listen to think twice, Michael Jackson, wherever you get your podcast, or you can binge the entire series at free, unaudible, or the Amazon Music App. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.